hi guys I'm Greg out but I'm John old
Humphrey
welcome back you might have just caught
our reaction to How to Train Your Dragon
2 hidden worlds trailer number 2 reason
we're doing this review part on a
separate video as opposed to the
reaction is because of the fact
occasionally our videos get blocked
sometimes it's the nature of this kind
of business
am i right am i right anyway let's pick
it up right from where the reaction
ended well that looks like a pure joy of
film right there so much to look forward
to so much to look forward to with this
movie the have strange dragon films this
seems like that there might be a little
bit of some predictability I guess the
thing that is just the most uncertain of
elements is how exactly will the end
being play out it's like the best guests
in our do you have is all the dragons
are probably all gonna have to live
together in this hidden world it seems
like Humanity
wherever Berk is they all like the
dragons but for the longest time and
then going back to the first movie they
did it their whole life was a revolving
around them it seems like everyone from
honoring dragon yeah it seems like
everyone outside of leichtberg and
hiccups mom everyone in this world got a
kill dragon kill them you know we gotta
make sure they're not free usually you
can't live amongst the Dragons in terms
of the the whole world so I imagine that
probably all them are gonna have to end
up living in this hidden world another
Pandora yeah yeah you know the second
one offered of Pandora this one is
another one it's a better Pandora yeah
if more translucent colors and things
like and then you know of course like
the Night Fury that species is almost
extinct you know they finds the light
fury
you know the hiccups you know have to
get on people let's make some more
dragon babies you know what I'm saying
I'm kind of wondering at the end of the
second one hiccup does something that
the happen soon where he becomes the
alpha dragon right I only saw one time
but I have a slight memory I've got one
shot here or you know he's like roaring
all the other dragons so see you just be
like the ultimate alpha like all the
dragons that we can say perhaps yeah I
mean it certainly looks like he's about
to become like king of the drag world
which you know I mean toothless
special dragon Plus that could be you
know his ruling Queen right there in the
light fury and they can be pressured to
repopulate the world with their own yeah
I guess my other question is Drago lives
at the end of How to Train Your Dragon 2
we don't see him in this trailer but I
think around the two-minute mark
somewhere around here let's surround
that shot with toothless and everything
yeah I think you see this bewilder beast
I was at the end of How to Train Your
Dragon 2 the one that you know toothless
turned into a little [ __ ] yeah what I'm
hoping for in this sequence maybe this
is the moment in the movie where they
explain what happened to drug when
there's a really violent flashback where
they show the Dragons like eating ham ya
know like feasting upon his bone playing
with his lint rails yeah I want to be
really darks the cached always destroy
your enemy yeah yeah yeah revenge is the
dish best served cold yeah and and for
kids yeah yeah and girls should learn to
be toothless yeah get some pliers and
rip max don't worry if kids are watching
they're gonna know that joke no thing
that struck me most about this trailer
oddly enough is just how like the first
how to train a dragon had beautiful
animation and and imagery and so the
second one but this one looks even
further into the future of just how
wonderful the textures look how great
yeah fire look and like one of the
greatest things about both of those
movies it's like I don't even love 3d
movies but some of those flight
sequences with the Dragons yeah
are incredible especially that last shot
where they're like dropping down through
the clouds and stuff like that like that
got me really excited those elements to
go back and revisit the world just for
how rich it's gonna look yeah well it
seems like before the all's lost moment
occurs that they're all on their own
all the people in Berk like this looks
like they either have no dragons or have
very limited dragons because they show
up in those like but what are those kind
of suits called oh those like bodysuit
those like doesn't call people those
yeah yeah yeah
sailing thing but to have like kind of
this medieval look about it you know
because of the time period that we're in
there's a pretty cool effect to it
because of one of the things that these
movies have always sort of dealt with
even in the first one is like learning
to fly the dragon is dealing with you
know physics of flight yeah a wing yeah
and now we're including this element
here and I got a whole squad of these
yeah so I'm kind of wondering like okay
at this moment in the film do they not
have dragons so they have to resort to
this and they get their dragons back and
get in the bow because right now this
this other hunter who apparently has
like killed so many knight theories and
whatever kind of just seems like a wider
version of Drago first movie is sort of
about tolerance it about you know it's
like okay we got a stop killing dragon
the second movie has like somebody else
is coming after the dragon this one
feels again like and another somebody
else yeah coming after the Dragons and
so I'm wondering what will make this
villain truly unique yeah as opposed to
Drago did you guys stand up for
tolerance hey it doesn't work yeah I
mean will the first movie I feel like
this is gonna probably have a really
cool art because the first movie is
about like the Burke and stoic I think
it's his name stoic yeah Labe big
sellers and they all hate dragons and
then by the end of it you know they
learn like you know maybe we can work
with these dragons and the second one
there very much domesticated in Berk and
they're protected him this one picks up
works kind of a utopia of dragons and it
looks like by the end now that you know
they've developed a good relationship
with them they're gonna release them to
be free and back into the world they
belong in instead of being people yeah
live your lives cuz there was this shot
it's not in this trailer but there was a
shot in the other trailer hiccup had a
beard and there was only one time but
toothless was with him so it kind of
confuses me a little bit when I think
about it okay wait a minute is it is he
like Ryu
with toothless's toothless stay behind I
know this is blue Slee based on the
books so I have no idea how accurate
what even happens in the books but then
that wouldn't make sense to me of how
like the plot of this is going around
we're excited I feel like there's a lot
more in store for this movie and there's
probably gonna be a surprise type of
ending that we're all not it's like
we're probably gonna get some of what
we're expecting but then a lot something
different as well it'll be the kind of
thing where like hiccups walking off you
know the new leader of men like you know
I gave up you know I let toothless go
off and be the leader you know that's my
art cuz I learned to let go and let him
be his own person but then too who can
come back last second it could be like
nah let's just go on adventures for the
rest of our lives and then like you know
open up the door to a whole other series
of How to Train Your Dragon films or
it's just the two of them riding around
the world kicking ass well they are
working on spin-offs I am sure they are
because this is a very successful
franchise with that sometimes I kind of
saw if you're doing Jay Baer shoulder a
little Nikki Bob I need to come back
with Jay Baer she'll leave I feel like
now is a good way to get people's
interest back and I also like the
opening of this trailer talking about
this is Berk yeah again you need that
with all of them right boobies come so
far apart here are my people what this
world is it's a very forgiving yes this
is specific theaters waits for that like
very guys this looks like a delightful
film I'm excited to check it out hey
before we wrap this video up I want to
give a patron of the day shout out to a
man named James stake ins James I gotta
let you know something buddy I know that
in the boring town you live in with the
people around you you don't like that
life can be kind of on the pessimistic
side I totally get that dude I totally
get that but if there's one person on
patreon who I know has the capability of
being someone like hiccup it's not you
it's not you I think you are destined to
stay in the zone you are in life is not
gonna get any better as a matter of fact
don't even get a pet is you would not
know how to take care of it dude so just
be alone
and lock yourself in your room with
cigarettes don't come out and you do
best to avoid interacting with any loved
ones strangers or animals and the most
important moral the story is don't be
yourself because if you're different
from you know the people around you you
don't belong and you should leave and be
alone and that's why you're in this
version of How to Train Your Dragon so
guys go check out our patreon today it's
worth it
James you know I'm not kidding never
ever
we love James so much he know all joking
aside take that shout out think the
opposite yeah you would be the real life
real hiccup because you're a good
rigging guy alright guys well what do
you think I've had a trader dragging the
hidden world this is gonna be your
favorite movie of 2019 probably probably
it'll be forgotten about by the end 29
things coming out so early you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and make sure to
go ahead and download the Stardust app
and follow us there 30-second
reactionary film TV show or trailer do a
lot of posting over there sometimes with
little micro sketches go ahead down the
app to check us out today thanks for
tuning in